we're in the shadows of Katie's
hairspray I love it I love this jacket I
do I bought it I tore the tag off now
her dad wants it
wants jacket hi Dad
hi Dad
can you have it or not
um well
[Music]
you're back pretty easy you know these
contestants weren't the only ones to see
you at Stagecoach this weekend I was
there on Friday you have a good time
well you know how to put on the show but
I knew that I saw your Dodger Stadium
yeah well we we had fun at Stagecoach
and we were glad that the um contestants
could come down there and um that's the
thing I mean they know us they know us
in our role behind the desk and we tell
them a lot of uh we give them a lot of
of uh you know feedback Through The
Years so
um it's nice for them to see that you
know we're at we're not you know blowing
smoke so you actually do perform to all
these crowds and stuff yeah other well
also you know announced a new single I
saw Ryan got a first listen what was his
reaction well um I felt like it was
genuine nah he he had a good time I was
begging him to you know maybe launch it
on top 40 radio but nah but yeah it's
called but I got a beer in my hand and
it's just a big old fun summer jam that
that you know it's been a little minute
since I've kind of put out like a real
like a I call it like a boat song like a
lake song a song song you can party on
party you know at the lake too so uh I
think it'll be a fun summer hit and I'm
really excited about the music that I
got coming coming down the pipeline beer
sales are just about to Skyrocket aren't
they
I think beer sales are always safe
speaking of safe you guys saved Oliver
tonight what a show how happy are you
hold on Katie's saying no I'm playing
she did HUD already if I'm going down
we're all going oh she she huddled just
to uh tell us her decision okay
you agreed no I did agree
so
I really are a family
do you hear these siblings it's like
this every week is it no well we're you
know we're having we're having so much
fun I mean and and and
you know we we it's just a fun thing to
be in you know when we see these kids
grow and we used Katie used the term you
know uh butterfly and developing into
these uh artists in front of our eyes so
we were happy with Oliver I mean
obviously top ten it's always
you know and what's funny is you know
anytime we do judges saves we get uh we
get roughed up pretty good on the
socials oh yeah we we get we get hit
pretty good but Kitty knew what she was
doing by being hey let me ask these two
too what they yeah
but uh it's all fun we'll all we'll all
go down together either way
um you
uh you and Ryan are holding down the
fort next week with Alanis Morissette
and Ed Sheeran how excited are you for
them to join the fun yeah I mean I think
it'll be a fun New Look I'm excited to
meet them
um I I hadn't ever had a chance to spend
some time with them but it'll be uh
it'll be a fun uh moment and
um really really honored that they
decided to come be a part it's going to
be a great look and and you know um with
Lionel and Katie going to England
um going to London I mean we were we
were we were wondering what what to do
and I think what we uh what we chose to
do is perfect it's going to be a blast
light on Kitty were shaking a little bit
I think I think
the main thing is
um after six years together like we all
know pretty much like we all know how to
work together it's just going to be
interesting to hear new versions of new
critiques and maybe I can take you know
still a couple lines from from Ed and
Alanis and uh you know get a little get
a little you know one-up Katie and
Lionel when they get back is there any
hazing that's gonna happen courtesy of
you I'm gonna stay out of stay out of
all that nothing
[Music]